- What really is a problem
and I think it's a developing problem,
we're no longer at the point Dave
where it's Republican versus Democrat.
This is now Washington
versus the rest of America.
(calm music)
- This is The Rubin Report
and I'm still Dave Rubin.
Reminder everybody to subscribe
to our YouTube channel
and click that fancy notification bell.
Joining me today is the former
American ambassador to Germany
as well as the former acting director
of US National Intelligence, Rick Grenell.
Welcome back to The Rubin Report.
- Thanks Dave, thanks for having me.
Good to see you.
- It's good to see you, I appreciate you
doing this my friend.
This is your first interview
since stepping aside
as Acting Intelligence Director.
So I normally don't do
an interview this way.
You know how I like to do it.
I like to just sit down
and go but I actually have
some bullet points and I just
want to just plow through
a whole bunch of stuff with you
but I think the first most important thing
is you talk a lot about the deep state.
Trump talks a lot about the deep state
and yet when a lot of us
talk about the deep state
people say oh this is a conspiracy theory,
this is made up, it's not really a thing.
There's no way to define it.
So when I say deep state to you,
what does that actually mean?
- I think to me what it
means is that there's this
system in Washington D.C.
the federal government system
that basically takes care of its own.
You have to be living in
Washington D.C. to work
for the federal government largely.
I know there are people
that'll say that's not true,
there's different you know,
offices around the country.
I certainly wish that there were more
because what really is a problem
and I think it's a developing problem,
we're no longer at the point Dave
where it's Republican versus Democrat.
This is now Washington
versus the rest of America
and what I would say
that the deep state is
is this system in Washington
that protects its own.
Everybody who gets a job
in the federal government
has to live in that area largely
and that means that they float
from one agency to another.
They're dependent upon
the federal government.
The media that lives there is dependent
upon Washington D.C. being
large and big and powerful
and when Republicans or
outsiders like Donald Trump
come in say you know
what, let's shrink this,
let's cut this, let's change this,
there is this rise up of
people protecting their city,
protecting the state
that they have built up.
And when we have economic crashes,
Washington D.C. is never hit
because the federal government
has a bunch of workers
that continue getting paychecks.
When we had COVID and people were cut,
why is it that all of the people
that were standing up saying stay at home,
don't work, put on a
facemask, don't go out
and participate in the commerce,
all of the people warning
us and telling us that
were people who had jobs.
All of Washington D.C. kept getting paid,
all of Washington D.C.
workers were staying at home,
they didn't have a care in the world
because they weren't working
but they were collecting
the same paycheck.
They are unaffected largely
when there is a crisis
and so it's this system
that takes care of its own.
Let me also just say it quickly,
when a job is opened up, let's say
at the Director of National
Intelligence Office,
of ODNI where I worked.
We post the job on these websites
that are only known by
Washington D.C. types
or largely known by Washington D.C. types.
They know the lingo, they
know how to go the office
'cause it's a local office.
They have been the deputy
assistant secretary
of this and that and then they get to be
the assistant secretary of this and that
and it builds on this oh,
well you have to have the
federal government lingo,
access and job title
in a consecutive order
in order to get the bigger jobs.
So it's a system that
takes care of its own
and when an outsider comes in,
threatens the whole
system like Donald Trump.
- So I actually wanted to
get to this a little later
but I think it's the right segue.
Can you talk about how that system then
is linked to the mainstream media.
How every article that comes
out in the New York Times
that is supposedly in
a classified meeting,
suddenly gets to the New York Times first
and then CNN and the rest of it.
How they're actually working in cahoots?
- Yeah, look it's, it's not that different
than say you know, we're in Los Angeles
and so the Hollywood crowd
and the Hollywood media
go to the same parties,
they go to the same church,
they live on the same block,
they see each other at the post office.
So there's this
institutional system right?
If you're working at say, Disney
and suddenly you're switching jobs
and you're working at NBC
and you get a bigger job,
you're still talking to the same people
in your neighborhood
and you're still talking
to the same media.
The relationships begin to be incestuous
and you take care of each other
because you're fighting for Los Angeles.
The same thing happens in Washington.
So when the media go to Washington,
you know the Jeffersonian
principle is that politicians
and people are supposed
to go to Washington
on a temporary basis.
Washington is supposed to
be this temporary place.
It's now got sports teams.
It's now got huge infrastructure.
It's got systems like a
city and now they're saying
we should be a state because
we have so many people.
That's not the design of Washington D.C..
Washington D.C. is
supposed to be the place
where you go temporarily to make laws
and then you leave that place
and you go home and live under those laws.
We have a system right now
where the media control it
because they live there
and they switch from the
New York Times to Politico
to The Washington Post, to CNN
and all around they
just stay in that system
and they protect their own.
And so I think it's a real
problem and by the way,
term limits is not gonna solve it.
It's an, it's one aspect of it.
But if you limit the politicians terms
to six years or whatever,
you're giving more
power to the bureaucracy
and to the deep state
because they're there.
And the person who just cycles
out is the politician that's,
that's the name on the door.
And the power becomes those staffers.
Now one solution 'cause I wanna always
talk about solutions.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Is that we need to move
some of this bureaucracy out
into the Midwest, into
the rest of the country.
Why is it, and I think COVID
is the perfect example to show
when there's a problem,
when there's a crisis,
we shouldn't have everything
based in Washington D.C.,
that's not healthy.
And so is there a way to start moving
parts of the bureaucracy to Kansas?
To Missouri, to Colorado?
To some of the other places where,
then the people who are
making these decisions
and living in the neighborhoods
have more American values
than Washington D.C. values.
- How do you think Trump saw this thing?
Like this is basically what he ran on,
drain the swamp and I don't
think people really knew
exactly that meant the deep
state as you're discussing.
And I think they meant, I think
most people thought he meant
oh drain the swamp.
Like ah just, just sort
of career politicians
but not like a structure.
Just like people who we vote in,
just the politicians sort of.
Why?
- Yeah.
- Have you ever talked to him about that?
Like how did this New York businessman
see that thing that most of us didn't see?
- You know I talked to
him a little bit about it,
one of the things that's
really interesting
about President Trump is
he's always been an outsider.
Even as a billionaire in New
York and a big developer,
he's always been an outsider,
he's always been somebody
who the system has looked at
with suspect and so,
he has the innate quality to
kind of take on the system,
take the criticism, be
tough through the criticism.
Not let the criticism effect him
and that's a powerful combination.
I also think it's why there's
a lot of gay conservatives
and black conservatives
who are tough enough
because they've grown up
against the system of you know,
you and I know this is that
the gay leadership in Washington D.C. says
that you have to think like this
otherwise you're not gay enough.
Our friend Peter Thiel
was called not gay enough.
And so there's this you know,
ideology now about being gay.
What's interesting about President Trump,
he recently told me that
when he came to Washington
D.C. for the inauguration,
to be sworn in as the 45th President,
he had never spent the
night in Washington D.C..
He had been there.
He had been there for the day.
But he had never spent the night.
Imagine spending the night
in Washington D.C. for
the first time and you're
spending it in the White House.
That's pretty amazing.
- Wow, that is incredible.
You know I was gonna do a
whole interview with you
and not mention the gay thing but since,
since you threw it out there,
in the last couple days
now that you're stepping away.
- I can't help myself.
It's such a part of me.
- The gay thing, let's
just do it for a second
because in the last
couple days you've posted
a couple pictures of
you in the Oval Office
and you know, I've talked about you know,
David and I going to
Mar-a-Lago and meeting Trump
and how he was so happy
that a gay couple was there
and couldn't have cared less.
People have heard that
story and they've heard you
talk about that but you
posted a picture of you, Matt,
your partner Matt and Vice President Pence
and a lot of people will
say all right, fine.
Maybe Trump doesn't care about the gays
but Pence really hates them and you know.
And yet, you describe him as a friend
and a good man and the rest of it
Could you do that in like a minute
and then let's get back
into the intelligence stuff.
- Yeah he's, Mike Pence
is an amazing person.
He's a committed
Christian, he's a realist,
he's somebody who's just
so nice and thoughtful.
We talk about Dietrich Bonhoeffer a lot.
He's, he's a Christian
philosopher that we really both
believe in and enjoy.
I feel like you know, I grew
up Evangelical Christian
as you know.
I feel like Mike Pence
is like my uncle, my dad,
my you know, many people in the church.
He is just a good guy.
He doesn't hate anybody.
He is so nice and he's just religious
and so we can have some sort
of different religious beliefs
or beliefs on social issues and
still be really good friends
and I think that's where we are.
I love him, he always
reaches out to Matt and me
and he's just an amazing guy.
- All right, now let's jump back.
We'll leave the gay
thing, was that enough?
Was that enough of the gay?
- We'll see.
- Enough of the gay.
Okay so when you left the
ambassadorship in Germany,
suddenly all these
diplomats were you know,
publicly saying all these
bad things about you
and how you've abandoned
them and blah blah blah.
And basically, I think why Trump hired you
is you called out everybody on Twitter.
You were basically like oh you know,
that's not what you said behind
closed doors or you know,
we actually want you to pay for things.
Yes, that's what we're trying to do.
It seems pretty obvious to
me that in your short stint
as acting Intelligence secretary director,
that you brought that in.
Can you, can you talk about
just bringing that attitude in
and like the type of stuff that
you pissed people off about
in the intelligence community?
- First of all I hope that you know me
and I hope that everybody that knows me
knows that I am actually
a very nice person
and cordial and never rude.
I do happen.
- You laid in.
You laid in bed with Emma
when she had only like
three days left of life last
time you were at my house.
So yeah, I can vouch for you.
- Look I, I am a cancer survivor
and I talk about that a lot because it,
it really has changed me.
I think I'm a better
person because of cancer,
because of this terrible
Non-Hodgkin's lymphoma.
But I hope that I'm
always bringing humanity
and a heart to even tough
conversations and so I'm,
I'm having these tough
conversations at a time when
it's really important to be blunt right?
To be direct, can you hear that phone?
Do you want me to?
- [Dave] That's all
right, that's all right.
It's the deep state calling
man, you're in trouble.
- Okay.
And so what I believe is
that we shouldn't have
these conversations behind closed doors.
We shouldn't have them in secret.
When diplomats were first
pushed to their country
from the United States,
you had diplomats that would get on a boat
and take a letter and they
would deliver a letter
of what the U.S. policy
is to the foreign minister
of another country and there
would be about three people
that would know what that policy is.
We now have changed with technology.
You get to do diplomacy
through what we call public diplomacy.
Reaching the public and
garnering the public support.
There are a whole bunch
of people in this world
of diplomacy who still
want that conversation
in the backroom of the foreign ministry
where four people get to decide what to do
and the public will get
spoonfed when they are told
that they are ready to get
spoonfed and I don't like that.
I'm just a different person.
I want access, I think you know,
when you look at how
technology has changed banking.
We don't, we no longer go to
the bank and have a teller.
We get to go to the ATM
or I get to transfer money
from my home.
It's upset a whole bunch of
industries including journalism
and so I think it's upset diplomacy
and the last people that
are comfortable with it
are the diplomats.
So they want me to quietly
come to the foreign ministry
and just talk about the foreign
policy that we want to them
in the back room, in a quiet way
and I was tweeting and I was talking about
how we're developing policy.
I think that that's better.
I think it's a better system.
Arguably somebody can
come back and say no,
it's not a good system.
I get a lot of people on Twitter who say
that's unprofessional
or you're no diplomat
and I look, I can take all that criticism,
it's silly criticism.
I think that the people wanna participate
and I am somebody who largely believes
that the people are smart enough.
A whole bunch of people think that people
aren't smart enough and that
we need to tell them what to do
and I think that we have a better policy
and a better system when
we can include the public
and listen to the public and
respond to what they want.
- So then speaking about
what the people know
and can know and can't
know and the rest of it,
I've heard you talk
about how too many things
are classified.
That then we can't figure
out what's going on.
How do they decide, they?
How do they decide what
is actually classified,
what gets unclassified, what,
who gets masked and
unmasked and the rest of it.
This'll probably get us
to the Flynn stuff too.
- It's such an interesting
question and again,
I don't think I can answer this question
without giving a little bit of context
that the system, the
intelligence community system
and Adam Schiff and Senator Mark Warner
all came at me and said this
guy doesn't have experience.
He is inexperienced and he is,
he is somebody that we should reject
because he doesn't have experience.
Now the fact of the matter is,
my first intelligence
briefing was in 2001.
I understand what this
system is all about.
I have been a receiver of
intelligence briefings,
a consumer of intelligence.
I've utilized it inside
the UN Security Council,
I've utilized it in Europe
to move Germany towards
banning Hezbollah for instance.
With Iran sanctions
I've used intelligence.
So the idea that I don't
have experience was silly.
I've had intelligence
briefings before Adam Schiff
and before Mark Warner.
Both of them criticizing me.
I just have a different perspective right?
I come at it from a consumer of it,
not somebody who wrote the
intelligence or the assessments
or been the analyzer of it.
So, when you look at this from
the outside with fresh eyes,
you look at intelligence
and you say largely,
why is this classified?
I read this in the paper.
Or this is, shouldn't be classified
just because it protects
the reputation of the CIA
or the FBI or the NSA.
There are times after certain years
when we know something
was going on like the,
the Russian investigation
and now we know that it was a big hoax.
I think that it's really important
to have the public see from the beginning
what was decided, what
intelligence officers
and others believe to
be suspect information.
What kind of pressure they were getting
from politicians at the time.
I wanna open this up, largely because
we made a huge mistake
like with the WMD issue.
The Russian hoax falls
right into that category.
Intelligence is an estimate.
I think there are good people
in the intelligence community
that are working really hard.
We have some bad apples,
just like we have bad apples
in journalism and in the police force.
We have bad apples but that doesn't mean
that we condemn everybody in
the intelligence community.
It means we gotta get out the ones
that are trying to be partisan with it
and so I was pretty good about
having fresh eyes and come,
I was pretty comfortable I should say
about having fresh eyes on the process
and saying this shouldn't be classified
and I don't know why somebody did.
So I would declassify it.
Or I decided that this period of time
between the election
of Donald Trump in 2016
in November, and the
inauguration of Donald Trump,
this is the transition
period where the Trump team,
the national security team and Flynn
are starting to get
acclimated to the issues
because they are now anointed
by the American people
as the incoming national security team.
If you look at some of the transcripts
that I declassified from Susan
Rice and from Samantha Power
they will both tell you
in those transcripts
which they were under oath
in the House Committee,
they said sure we talked to foreigners
when we were transitioning
from Bush to Obama.
During our transition
we were talking to foreign governments.
They said that the
difference was that they had
a State Department person
you know, in the meeting.
Somehow that that was
gonna make a difference.
I think what we saw with
the Flynn Trump transition
is that people were
interested in learning issues.
They were talking like
they were diplomats.
I think when you see that
transcript of Michael Flynn
you think wow he's, he's a good diplomat.
He's trying to calm the
situation down with the Russians.
He's not trying to inflame it.
He's not trying to say
screw them or screw us.
He's trying to say, you know,
let's think strategically about
this and have reciprocity.
So if we do something then
you can come back and do it
but let's not go crazy here
with coming at each other's throat.
- All right, so then for
people that can't get too
in the weeds on all of this,
then what is the problem
with the unmasking?
And really how high up does it go?
And also, just relative to everything
going on in the world right now,
do you think it's worth
spending a lot of time
trying to actually
figure out what happened
when we're in the midst of well,
corona, it's hard to
tell what's real anymore.
But we are in the midst of
riots and everything else.
- All good questions, kind
of difficult questions.
What I would say first
is that unmasking a name
is not in and of itself a bad thing.
I do think, and the reason
why I released the list
of unmaskers between election
day and inauguration day is,
that's a higher bar for me.
To want to dig down and to
know who's talking to whom
when we already know who is coming in
as the national security team,
you shouldn't be concerned about that.
Unless you're looking
to play politics and so,
the idea that you would unmask before
we know who the President
is, before election day,
I didn't release that information.
Because I see where you
could make an argument
of how you need to know what's going on
in order to blunt some sort of you know,
actions from a foreign government.
But it's different Dave
when we know who's incoming
and you have the Obama team
in the way that they were doing it,
at very high levels and in the frequency,
during the transition,
they know who's coming in
and yet they can't help
themselves, they're digging deep
and then what we know is that
the FBI said very clearly,
there's not enough information here.
Let's drop the case on
Flynn and the very next day,
there's an Oval Office meeting with Comey.
Now this is clear.
The Obama Administration weaponized
the intelligence agencies to go after
their political enemies.
I don't care what anyone
tries to spin and say,
that's exactly what happened.
And you look at the
evidence from election day
to inauguration day,
that is the time period
that they should've said okay we're out.
We're, we're in transition out.
They are now going to be
out and they need to be
passing the torch for the American people
to the next people that were just elected
by the American people.
Instead, they were so shocked
that they developed this Russian narrative
and I wanna make one thing clear.
The Russians interfered
in our election debate.
Largely on social media and
they utilized propaganda.
I have written extensively on this issue
about what the Russians
have done in Eastern Europe.
They constantly go after countries
when there's an election.
They use propaganda,
a tiny sliver of truth
and they blow it out to make it completely
an erroneous story.
This is what the Russians do,
I am very clear eyed on it.
I have condemned them, I have written.
I have some of the, I was
one of the first people
to write on what the Russians
did against Voice of America
and Radio for Europe in Eastern Europe
and so I am very clear on how
they do this in elections.
They did it to us but that's no surprise,
they always try to use
propaganda in our elections
to sow chaos.
The difference is is that the
media developed and blurred
this Russian election debate propaganda
into manipulating the Russian,
the American election.
Most people will hear that
the Russians interfered
in our election.
That's a big jump to say when they've
clearly used propaganda,
largely on social media to,
to jump in and inflame our debate
so that we fight against each other.
And so I think that the
media did the Russians
a real service.
They inflamed the debate even more
and they utilized the
very small investment
that the Russians put in,
and they got a whole bunch of earned media
from our American media.
- Yeah all right.
So if we were to whittle this down
to its simplest terms,
the intelligence community
said there's nothing there.
Then there's this meeting
with Comey at the White House
and now we know, then this
becomes like a two year run.
Basically to try to prove
some kind of collusion.
So if that is in fact true.
So I'm taking your word
for that being true.
So if that is true, then,
then in effect you're saying
we have to investigate this all the way
and that could really take out I mean,
pretty much everybody right?
I mean everybody in the
previous administration.
- What I think Dave is important
and what I learned through
eight years at the UN
is that kind of this
transparency and truth
and reconciliation is really important.
When you have a crisis
and you have a problem.
Let's come clean and I,
and I fundamentally believe in what I,
I think that the intelligence community,
the current intelligence community,
not the former intelligence community
that the New York Times
and the Washington Post
constantly quote, you'll
notice they always say
a former intelligence official.
That's clearly a former person
who was a political appointee.
- Yeah it's also a source on Capitol Hill
who could be a janitor,
you just don't know.
- Yeah, the current intelligence community
was clamoring for reform
which I delivered.
It wasn't, truly it wasn't,
most of these ideas were not my ideas.
I just said yes to them
because the system was
saying we need to reform.
And the current intelligence
community believes
there are a couple of bad apples
that they've gotta get out there
and that they were manipulated.
And I will say this.
There were red flags early on
in the Russian investigation
from a variety of agencies and some people
made those red flags and those comments
from people coming forward
and saying this Russian stuff is not true.
They classified that
information and pushed it away.
I've seen that information
and I've called for it
to be declassified.
It's a process that's
ongoing, it takes time.
I wasn't there long enough to do it
but there are instances
where red flags were raised
very early on in certain agencies
and I have requested that
information to come out
and I hope that it will.
- All right so just two more quick for you
'cause I know you're tight on time.
So the first one is
sort of simple which is,
why not stay there?
Did President Trump not want you to stay
or did you not wanna stay?
I mean it seems like you're
clearly the guy for the job
but it was only, you know, it
was a couple of months really.
- So you know, I've been
in Germany for two years
and I really decided when we went there
that we weren't just gonna
have parties at night
and I wasn't gonna do a travel log
of how great Germany was,
I was the US Ambassador and
I was gonna work really hard
to push on US policy and we did.
We worked really hard and
I had an amazing embassy,
foreign service officers
who are truly great people
who wanna do good work and they
were hungry to do good work
and it's exhausting and look,
I, I'm totally healthy, I feel great.
But I'm also very
sensitive about you know,
not taking it too far.
I had a cancer scare and
it was a pretty serious one
that came up fast.
I'm still getting checked
every three months.
I you know,
in all honestly I think that
has a little bit to do with it.
I was tired, I had in my mind
thought that we'd only do
about two and a half years
and then when the President
called and asked me to
temporarily do DNI I said 90 days
and it turned out to be more
than 90 days 'cause of COVID
but I'm just somebody
that when I have the job
I don't wanna sit there and
just collect a paycheck.
I'm gonna do it to the best of my ability
and when I got in, I
decided to go and reform it
because people were clamoring for it
and a lot of politicians
on Capitol Hill got angry
'cause they wanted me to just sit there.
You're the Acting, you're
not supposed to do anything
and I said you know, only
in Washington D.C. are you
supposed to take a job and just sit there
and not do anything.
In the rest of the world
when you take a job
you actually do the job.
- Yeah I saw you had a
couple tweets about that.
People were angry that
you were doing the job
which is sort of D.C. 101.
Okay so just one more for you
that sort of is about
everything going on right now.
As we watch the protests and
the riots and everything else,
I think a lot of people are wondering,
something like that this
doesn't feel organic.
That antifa which now, it sounds like,
did the President actually classify them
a terrorist organization
or that's in motion or?
Do we know where it's.
- I think it's motion.
It happened when I was on my way out
so I think what has happened is is that
the Attorney General has classified them
and they're now making
the, the appropriate steps
which means you can go
after their finances,
you can freeze their finances.
And everybody involved.
- So with that in mind.
- So accounts.
You know the, let's just
put people on warning here.
The accountants for these people,
the banks that fund the money,
the workers that work in these businesses
that the person is a CEO or affiliated
or an owner of some sort.
So there's a whole bunch and
I think the family members,
if you've got joint bank accounts
are also gonna be effected.
- Yeah you probably saw this but Andy Ngo
is now suing Rose City Antifa
and I have a feeling once
they get into discovery
it's gonna take out blue check journalists
and New York Times people.
- Yep.
- And progressive nonprofits
and the whole thing.
But my specific question on that is,
it feels like as we watch
the riots everywhere
and you know, unfortunately well you know,
I'm here in L.A. and New York City,
like most of the progressive cities
are the ones that are burning.
Do you guys have any evidence
of how much of this was
actually coordinated beforehand
and did you sense that this
was coming at some point?
Because if not, that does seem like
some sort of intelligence failure right?
'Cause this thing
is still ongoing.
- Yeah.
What I can say is I know
that they're looking into it.
I was on my way out by the
time that this was developing
and so I know that there are
teams of people looking at it.
We've got an amazing
counter terrorism center.
We've got counterintelligence
people who are experts
in looking into these issues.
I know specifically through
the intelligence community
and people who work at ODNI that they are
completely focused on
this and there's one thing
that I can say is that Bill Barr
is a great American who
wants to be thorough,
he wants to be fair, he
looks at the details.
And we're really lucky to have him.
- All right Rick, I
know I gotta let you go
but I am doing one bonus question which is
now that you're back in California,
I know you wanna relax a little bit.
You guys are gonna take some time
but this is my public
plea which will be put
on YouTube and Twitter and everywhere else
for Rick Grenell for
Governor of California.
Will you make that commitment,
or Mayor of Los Angeles.
Give me something man,
we need you, come on.
- Okay so what I will say is this,
is that my immediate plans
are to have a gin and tonic
at four o'clock and that's really how far
I'm focused on my life.
- So you're gonna be far more
productive than Gavin Newsom.
I think that's what you're saying.
All right well it's
great seeing you my friend.
- I will say this,
that California desperately
needs a new direction.
My fear is that everybody
is angry right now
at Gavin Newsom for locking us down
and I mean, shutting beaches down
when clearly science, evidence shows,
you should probably be on
a beach where it's hot,
where you can spread out.
The overreaction from
the, the control freaks
in Sacramento was frightening.
I know countless people
who voted for Gavin Newsom
who say never again, what was I thinking
and so I think he's ripe to be defeated.
The problem is is that it's years away
and so that intensity is
gonna you know calm down.
If he was up in November it
would be a different story
but he's gonna have to
work hard to come back
and you know, he's also been the leading
assault on our Second Amendment rights
and he's got some crazy
ideas when it comes to
you know, trying to take ammunition
and he basically chased out Olympians
who were shooters who
couldn't even practice
in California any longer
'cause they couldn't get their ammo.
That's how radical he was when it came to
our Second Amendment rights.
So there are a whole bunch of issues
that I think that you could
take on Gavin Newsom on
and somebody's going to.
- All right Rick, enjoy the gin and tonic.
Enjoy a little rest and I'm
gonna keep the pressure on you.
'Cause I don't think
it's not in your future.
I'll leave it at that
and everyone can follow you on Twitter
if you wanna see Rick smack down
some foreign diplomats
and lay out the truth,
it's @RichardGrenell.
If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist
and if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.